huge congratulations on your emmy noms
uh that's
awesome thank you so much
uh was this something that was even did
that even
for both of you did you even think that
this was something that the emmy nom
like did it even register
and all of a sudden you found out when
we shot it we didn't even know
you know we've what quippy was i mean
like
people were describing it to us but you
know it was a new platform and i i don't
think it really
occurred to us that
we would you know be nominated for an
emmy you know it was it was a brand
you know a brand new platform we were
kind of shooting it like a film and
curious to see how they were going to to
uh to bring it to the forefront and uh
so i think kind of you know the emmy was
like the last thing
on our mind you know going into the
project
you you don't even really really we
don't realize
rather um that it's every nomination day
and we'll kind of just wake up and you
know you get
a flurry of these messages and i think
you're you're grateful you're humbled
for a moment you're in disbelief um
because
you know i think we all just we took it
so personally
um just the work that we never thought
about awards
and so to be recognized in this way i
think it was a pleasant surprise
after watching the whole series um i
could understand why you were both
nominated uh you both did
fantastic work i'm i'm curious when you
were playing a role like this
or like these where it's intense and
you're feeling
there's a lot of emotion that you have
to portray on screen how easy is it for
the both of you to leave the character
on set at the end of the day and go back
to who you
are or you know what i mean does it
stick with you
to a point you have to shake it off in
order to
go to bed i i think we're
with this project we didn't hang out
really at all because
it took so much out of us emotionally
that by the end of the day we were
exhausted and it was just
going straight to bed and then waking
back up it's like knowing that you have
to give
that part of yourself so you you know
you you let like
a lot go but there's also a little bit
you hold on to
because you know you have to keep going
back to that
place inside of you so by the end you
know when we were done it was like a
relief of like
we can kind of like let that go and we
can like celebrate and oh my god look at
the amazing work that we just did
you know i think pretty much along the
lines of the jasmine saying
um you know you don't fully let it go
until it's
it's all over with um but
you know i i'd be lying you know line if
i said that
you know it was it was easy and then and
that you know you weren't giving a piece
of yourself to
you know projects like this i think that
anything of this magnitude uh requires
that you
you shed a little bit of yourself and
that's just a sacrifice that i think we
all accepted as artists
one of the things about this is that
it's unfortunately
as timely as ever uh the story that's
being depicted in
with free rashaan um can you sort of
talk about the fact that
uh i think stories like this are
incredibly important that they
keep on getting told to remind people
about you know what goes on can you can
you both sort of address that
we've been telling these stories for
years through our art and through
our music i mean you look at it you know
a marvin gaye album or any stevie wonder
album and
they're they're talking about this
subject um
i think it's it's come to a place where
everybody there's been a shift i feel
that's different um
that's that's that's happening right now
and free raishan has
just landed right in the middle of that
i feel like when you do projects like
this
um you you never know how it's going to
affect people or where it's going to
land and how it's going to land and i
think it's all kind of
coming at a place and a time that's
that's super super important
um we had no idea last year when we were
filming this that
everything was going to happen in the
way that it did and
um you know kind of come to head like
this
so it it's why we do it
it's why we pick projects like this it's
it's
this is why we do it you know it's
important it's a labor of love
it's it's it could happen to me it could
happen to jasmine
um you know it it becomes certain things
become
you know it's more than just going to
work every day and you know
waking up and running through the you
know the run of the mill
if you will um i think that there's a
personal investment
that comes with uh telling a story like
this and
that's obviously you know what's what's
you know transpired onto the screen
uh before i run out of time uh stefan i
actually have to ask you an individual
question
um i i've heard some rumblings that you
might be working with uh
rapman on a prophet uh is there any
truth to that
i have no comment on that i'm sorry got
it then i'll switch to something else
and uh uh one of the things that i
thought was so well done about this
is that qibi really knows how to sell
the cliffhanger as i was watching this i
kept on wanting to hit play
as fast as possible um can you sort of
talk about
the fact that these cliffhangers really
keep you invested as you're watching
you know obviously it's it's a very
important story and i think
there's when you usually see stories
like this
there's a lot of quiet movement moments
and it's a little bit slower but this is
also
an action piece and it's takes place
under 24 hours and
i mean it's i'm talking about high
stakes
uh so it's um
it's an interesting way you know to kind
of tell this story
um and requires kind of like all of
these cliffhangers and
you know we shot it like a film but um
the way that it was written
and and how quibby did the edits in the
room
i think um they really did a great job
of
you know every episode kind of like
leaving you what's gonna happen next
you know good luck with the rest of the
speed dating
i hope you end up doing a profit you
guys have a fantastic day
and uh talk to you guys later have a
great day